keep me awake so I could drink a drink
more and I did my share what made you
stop I was killing myself you know I
told you that did you is it someone you
listen to me but everybody kind of gave
up on me my uh Jennifer had given up on
me uh my mother had given up on me uh my
agents had given up on me and I you know
I've been in four rehabs I've been in
four rehabs and not that whole AAA thing
never never quite worked for me I don't
have that good of an attention span so
like I don't even know like what the
first step is let alone the third one or
the fourth one it never worked I think I
I just I was doing it because other
people told me I should do it uh and uh
but it got to a point where I was Rock
Bottom yeah in my mind I was rock bottom